Hey, I'm Jad and I'm Robert Doone duty and your topic remains.
Oops. Due to final loops coming up soon.
It's sort of a double hoops. I would say we start with an oops.
That leads to another oops. That then self negates.
It comes to us from a fellow who within the confines of the show we will call
oopsie wheeler,
so maybe we could just start with the both of you kind of introducing yourself
and saying who you are and what you do. I mean,
just something basically I'm Andrea sterly. Oh, me. I'm Donald Sterling.
This is dawn and Andrew Sterling. They're chemists.
They're actually a research team here at a University of Montana and they met
back in the 70s 1979 at the University of California in San Diego.
We met and almost fell in love at first sight.
We dated for a week. He proposed, I accepted.
They got married and not long after don got offered a job,
so they left their home in Sunny California. And mind you,
we lived about half a mile away
from the ocean. Nonetheless, they packed up a truck with all of our stuff,
including about 200 plants and they moved to a
Butte, Montana, which is a different thing altogether.
An old mining town that barely had a tree in the the city limits.
I don't know if you want to know Andrea's first impressions of Butte or not.
Sure. I actually burst into tears and then started laughing.
I think we call that history.
Yeah. The beauty standard used to be up on the hill over here when this was an
operating. Yeah,
so I actually grew up in the town over from Butte in Montana.
It's kind of that town that you were afraid to go to when you were a kid.
Filled with abandoned buildings, depressed,
and actually if you walk through town right there,
right next to the middle of town, remember exactly where it was.
I remember being this enormous open wound on the hill like, oh no,
this, this deep pit. This is where the pit is,
the Berkeley pit, and the guy saying, wow is Barrett Golding. I actually,
I couldn't get back to Butte myself,
so I asked Barrett to go over there and visit with a couple of engineers.
So tell me who you are. Okay, well I'm Joe Griffin,
Montana Department of Environmental Quality and I'm Nick Tucci.
I'm with the Montana Bureau of Mines and geology and I'm,
the three of them are standing at the edge of the pit,
which is kind of hard to imagine, especially the size of this thing.
But when you're at the edge of the pit and you look down in what you actually
see is how can you convey what we're seeing,
this enormous lake kind of, well,
it's 40 billion gallons of water, which is a lot of water.
It's one of the larger lakes in the United States is carved into this hill.
Yeah.
The main difference though between this lake in one that you might decide to
take an afternoon dip in, is that this lake is a bizarre color.
The water is red.
[inaudible]
is this kind of sickly red and also rains and gray and black.
Oh, it's technical.
[inaudible]
it shimmers in this way that like words can't describe.
And when you're standing there, you can't help but wonder
question.
I really have and I'll rephrase it after they ask it cause it's not quite,
is like what the,
I mean what happened? Well it's just a, you know, the price of copper
in the 1920s when we were stringing up telephone wires and electrical wires and
going through world wars,
a third of the copper in the u s came out of [inaudible]
this hill, you know, the long and the short of it is, um,
you wouldn't be standing here broadcasting this or recording this without copper
in your wire right there.
And in his heyday, you know,
before the pit was even around Butte was this mining boom town.
But by the 1940s, the price of copper drop,
a company that owned all the mines and BW wasn't doing so well and so they
figured it'd be cheaper and easier to just blow the top off the hill.
Things just kept getting worse.
And by 1982 right around the time when don and Andrea were coming to town,
taking over the mines completely shut down when they shut the pit in early 1980s
right? Here's the things, while they're actually mining,
they keep all the groundwater pumped out of there,
so that's dry and they can work and when they shut the mines down,
they shut off the pumps. The company turned off the pumps,
I think it was Earth Day 1982 yeah. On Earth Day after that,
the a p it started filling up with ground water and it took a good 10 years to
actually see a kind of a rust colored puddling in the bottom of the pit itself.
But it was a puddle that was growing and growing road and growing and growing,
growing. Now here's the thing about that water. The Rock around the pit.
It's filled with pyrite and when the water hits the Pyrite and the air three
react to create sulfuric acid.
Oh, in turn, that's Edwin Dob.
Freelance writer had been for about 20 years. I actually grew up in Butte.
The sulfuric acid hastens the removal of the metals from the,
or itself like gold and silver and copper, copper,
cadmium and growl sink,
iron sulfate syndrome.
And what you end up with is this toxic acidic disaster and it's still rising.
In fact, that, you know, since we started working on this piece,
Jad is arisen like about a foot.
Um, there was an incident, infamous incident in the mid 1990s.
Anybody who grew up anywhere near Butte knows this story. One stormy night,
some 340 snow geese landed.
They landed on the water looking for shelter and they of course drink some of
it.
The next day there were 342 goose carcasses floating on the water.
They were all dead.
And the autopsy showed lesions in the esophagus throughout the digestive system.
Oh, so it's like the water ate their insights. Yeah.
Were you struck at all like upon arriving there,
did you actually kind of go visit the mine?
The old mine site avoided it like the plague.
We were to staunch
environmentalist in the idea of living in a mining town was so completely
foreign. And when they first showed up in Butte, Don and Andrew,
they were kind of struggling to fit in at the university because they're trying
to study this, a little micro organisms sponge in Bermuda,
but they're in Butte and locked Butte, Montana.
To make matters worse when they took off for a year on Sabbatical,
our college accidentally unplugged our refrigerator,
destroying all of our samples on desperation.
Definitely had no funding. We decided we just needed to start over,
but one day a scientist named Bill Chatham came into their lab with a piece of
wood and on this wood there was some green, slimy stuff and he says,
you won't believe this, but I found this stick with the slime on it in the pit
floating about a foot below the surface of the water. Here's the thing,
I mean that lake is, this is like,
this is the most deadly place you can imagine. I mean,
nothing grows here. Nothing should grow here. Nothing. Absolutely not.
Not even anything but nothing. Yeah, less than nothing.
Maybe absolute nothing like negative numbers of nothingness.
It's more than nothing is an active getting rid of thing.
It's an a gating nothingness. You know how there's love and hate.
This is not a lack of love. This is hate. Okay.
But they got together with some colleagues.
They looked at the slime and they realized against all odds
the stuff was alive. Life, an acid mine,
waste life that no one had ever studied before.
It really is what started everything we've been doing now. Gosh,
for the last 15 years. [inaudible]
so far we found virtually hundreds of compounds, organisms that were growing,
organisms that make molecules that can fight viruses.
Several turn out to be good in our andi cancer screening by cancer. Really?
Yeah.
Burke lik acid in Berkeley amyloids and the Berkeley asked the towel is now
published. Tons of papers. I mean their work has just taken off,
so it's been pretty exciting research.
But then they told me this story that totally took them by surprise.
It was about a year after they'd first started looking at the Pittwater.
We found this sort of a sticky, opaque, thick,
gooey black organism. Then they noticed that weirdly,
if you put this little guy into a thing of the water from the pit,
it actually absorbs the metals in Pittwater. What does that mean?
Like they're taking the metals out of the water.
They become a little metal sponge. Yes.
But so they're cleaning the water is what you're saying? Yeah.
And there's lots of people that work with micro organisms to try to clean up
metal late in water. But usually these things taken maybe like, I don't know,
10, 15% of the metals,
this little guy will actually absorb between 85 and 95%.
Whoa. So they got really curious about it and they started, uh,
trying to figure out where it had ever been seen before we had it identified.
And they eventually discovered that the only place this yeast had ever been
found was
where?
Well, in the rectal swabs of geese.
Oh,
you mean like the snuggies that landed on the water? Yeah.
[inaudible]
the geese left
a little, uh, a little something behind
present.